[Musique]
retrouvez allons-nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la Réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission Ça ne sa découvre
la Réunion ensemble vous allez réparer
alors allons-nous
[Musique]
parler misérables alors dans la commune
de Saint-Paul plus précisément à
l'emital les Bains et ben nous nous
sommes
on est en train de faire une séance de
randonnée aquatique ce qu'on appelle la
randonnée aquatique le longecote
d'accord
ça consiste à marcher dans l'eau jusqu'à
une hauteur de
du nombril jusqu'aux essais et on
pratique des exercices dans l'eau donc
très bénéfique pour les articulations et
les et tous ceux qui ont déjà un certain
âge qui peuvent faire pratiquer le trail
tout ça donc ça ça permet de se
maintenir en forme surtout et c'est très
très physique les original notre
principal souci nous comité de la
randonnée c'est de trouver des spots
pour exercer notre
cette activité qui
demande certaines conditions les
conditions de marée des ah oui c'est la
marine pour autant que j'ai pas fait
n'importe quoi
et donc là pour l'instant on a donc ici
là l'Ermitage on a Saint-Pierre d'accord
à Saint-Pierre et on fait on va sûrement
essayer de à Saint-Leu de faire de
trouver la on n'a pas encore testé mais
on sait qu'on peut le faire donc en
terme de santé les vraiment bénéfique à
tout à fait tout à fait c'est
vous bénéficiez tous les avantages de
l'eau parce qu'on sait très bien que les
gens qui ont des problèmes
d'articulation qu'on a d'arthrose et
tout ça ils ont besoin de faire des
exercices dans dans l'eau et en plus il
y a c'est c'est très convivial il y a
pas de il y a pas de compétition il y a
pas de 1 on est pas là pour ce tirer la
bourre donc voilà la réunion nous les la
même mon pays comment il est la réunion
s'amène neuillère parle pas nous aller
nous verrez la même un peu de respect
pour mon pays la même vraiment après
depuis son lit bout de la terre dans
et on va aller voir ça
bonjour monsieur bonjour
comment allez bien bien
cuisson la réserve naturelle alors
donne-moi un peu ici et bien je suis
agent de la réserve marine et
j'accompagne là un groupe pour une
opération de sensibilisation sur un
sentier sous-marin au cours duquel on va
expliquer bien la le fonctionnement un
peu les bases du fonctionnement du récif
corallien et puis les menaces qui qui
pèsent sur ce récif corallien et du coup
aussi les les petits gestes importants
les éco-gestes qu'il faut respecter
quand on va se promener dans le lagon
pour rien abîmer d'accord et aujourd'hui
un niveau en a un groupe est-ce que
est-ce que vous pouvez venir visiter
justement sentir sous-marin c'est payant
c'est comment il se passe c'est gratuit
c'est une opération de sensibilisation
donc menée par la réserve naturelle
marine de la Réunion nos grands nos
grandes missions pour préserver le récif
corallien c'est d'abord de le connaître
donc on va faire des suivis
scientifiques
pour connaître l'état de santé et puis
pour avoir pour améliorer les
connaissances on va mener des opérations
de surveillance avec une partie de notre
équipe qui est qui sont des policiers de
l'environnement et puis et puis nous la
petite équipe de la petite cellule de
sensibilité animation on va recevoir en
priorité les scolaires pour pour leur
apprendre les bases les scolaires de
tout autour de la Réunion et puis quand
il s'est les vacances et que et qu'on a
un petit peu de temps parmi toutes nos
autres missions et bien on accueille
aussi le grand public et d'ailleurs
j'invite tout le grand public
réunionnais à venir participer à ses fun
et puis en même temps on apprend des
choses importantes quand vous étiez
Coincy en France
[Musique]
comme si la nature déconnait ah la la
paradis pour nous rester
ok ben voilà après la marche aquatique
la petite balade se marine
allez allons
bonjour monsieur aventure
[Rires]
et ici c'est quoi exactement c'est un
centre de vacances que c'est
ouvert
donc c'est un village vacances qui
accueille tout public pendant tous les
pays d'accord et après forcément sur les
périodes on a des aides que les accordé
et vrai ça a été fait au départ
population réunionnaise ou bonne idée de
famille réunionnaise mais il vient
profite des vacances j'ai le bord de mer
mais accessible vraiment tout le monde
grand diversité publique et est-ce que
et tout ça rendez vous un prochain
épisode de l'émission à nous c'est pas
il sera dans la commune de Salazie il ne
sera sur le piton de la semaine la
trouve
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présenté par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]